as the swim coach at covington min lee
selects which athletes will participate
in the statewide swim relay
the relay team swims two-thirds of a
mile altogether with each team member
responsible for swimming two-ninths of a
mile
the team must complete the swim in
three-fifths of an hour how many
swimmers does minlee need on the relay
team
now what we need to think about is
what's the total amount of mileage they
need to do what's the total distance
that they need to do so let's think
about the total distance
total distance
divided by
divided by the distance per swimmer
distance
distance per
swimmer
swimmer
swimmer
is going to give us the number of
swimmers that we need
number
of swimmers
swimmers so what's the total distance
that they need to go well we circled it
up here they need to swim two-thirds of
a mile together so the total distance is
two-thirds of a mile
the distance per swimmer that they need
to go or or the distance that per mile
that the the distance per swimmer that
the disc that each swimmer is going to
do is 2 9 of a mile each team member
responsible for swimming 2 9 of a mile
so divided by 2 9 of a mile and this is
going to give us the number of swimmers
we need and you could even put the units
here and it'll all work out so you get
the number of swimmers we don't care how
fast they need to actually complete it
we just care about for this distance
given how far each of them swims how
many people do we need this is actually
extra non-necessary information so
two-thirds divided by two-ninths this is
the same thing as
two-thirds
times the reciprocal of two-ninths which
is nine-halves
nine-halves and you you could well i'll
just multiply it out without multiplying
it out so this is the same thing as two
times nine
over three times two
we can divide the numerator and the
denominator by two
then this will become a one and this
will become a 1. we could have done it
at this stage 2. divide numerator and
denominator by 2 that would be 1 and
that would be 1 as well and we can
divide the numerator and denominator by
3. this will become 3 this would become
1. we could have also done it at this
stage dividing both of these by three
this is three this is one we're dividing
the numerator and the denominator by the
same thing well now our numerator
simplified to one times three which is
three and our denominator is simplified
to one times one which is one so this is
equal to three three swimmers is what we
need